before we go any further this video is
sponsored by raycon
invite did you get the invite when i
sent it done
invitation yeah let's proceed
hey i'm already having a
really bad frame rate drops it's not a
great start
how was your day oh yeah it's jumping a
little bit
okay
no he forgot about the dentist
appointment no today
i'm working tomorrow she's working
tomorrow
she's working tomorrow all the time why
don't we just go ahead and tell her
who is this haunted girl in our house
[Music]
she just found out that they're getting
a divorce
oh no she's haunted for sure yeah she's
definitely haunted
she's a voodoo dog none of this is good
this game is about exterminating the
ghost inside of this child
i don't feel good about it is that a
weed plant damn
she made dolls of her parents because
they fight all the time
oh that's so sad do we go what character
do you want or against the gender
roles i feel like i'm gonna give you the
british one so i'm actually going to go
no i have to i have to because you
identify as british
yeah you're way closer to the british
than me and australia
part of the commonwealth oh my god she
knows parkour
possess girl got cool i want to wear
overalls
you could wear overalls dude no you
could totally do that
i'm not she's crying grumpy does she
have magic tears
that's the ghost dude she do she do have
magic tears
don't she pogging this is how we get mom
and dad back together again
pagas is hell there you are oh that's me
that's you yeah those are my vibes if
i'm being honest
pretty much why do you always blame me
huh
yes oh what the [ __ ] oh hello oh
okay who is this gentlemen is so cute
oh my gosh you're here to fix your
relationship
his facial hair looks like gum wrappers
it probably is we need to fix our
relationship even
we need to fix our relationship yeah
we've had a lot of problems
and then and that's why we're getting a
divorce exactly in the four years that
we've
you know been in this marriage we've
really failed our daughter
i know we keep letting him go to the
bookstore by herself
and we can't keep doing it and you keep
missing your dentist appointment and i'm
like oh my god but you have gross teeth
because you're british
uh-huh how does it feel to date a
british woman
it's pretty hot you know the stuff she
says during bed he's like
[Laughter]
let's find a way oh this is really cute
okay okay yeah got it come help me pull
this timer
that's what you say when we're in bed
all right come help me pull this down in
it all right
boy babes come help me pull this down
we're dating an american is like uh just
uh you got any eagles out there can we
have
guns in the bedroom how's that sound
i can't finish in this side unless i'm
holding a gun
[Laughter]
i don't like it oh we get to go in the
things wow i'm looking at your
huge ass right now do you like that but
how do you feel about that it's pretty
great thank you oh you can sprint we can
sprint
that animation is very sweet this seems
unsafe okay we have we have to interact
yeah this seems very unsafe whoa
yeah wow this is so
fun okay jump dash comey
yeah all right now finally where the
[ __ ] are we
is our marriage fixed yet
this is the last one oh we've got to put
the last one in
boy we've got to pull it down all right
i love the pool my wife isn't it's not
just a british woman she's a [ __ ]
chap she's odd
she's from sprub that's why we fell out
she got too domesticated she got boring
now she's worried about dentist
appointment she used to be worried about
who she was going to stab next
no we're getting a divorce he's very
sassy
um okay they said collaboration so i'm
thinking we need to do different things
yes true just the same
okay
um how do i get you across probably this
yeah
yeah yeah make it go up
very easy yeah
look at us collaborating yeah i think we
should get remarried
i think so too this has really shown us
what love is all about
yeah i'll keep it out with my vacuum and
you can make out with that buckle yeah
okay bye
[ __ ] you know collaboration
[Laughter]
yeah you keep your sex life alive with
the vacuum
i'll [ __ ] some other dude
yeah let's see whatever seems like a
good exchange seems fair for both
parties
this is so cute it is very cute this is
so crazy i shrunk
my parents that are having relationship
problems and don't love each other
anymore
and also i'm possessed and i made voodoo
dolls of them don't worry about it it's
all fine
so perfectly that's fine you got to be
real patient with this
this looks dangerous he's right here
he's doing oh [ __ ] off
you [ __ ] [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] me
and then once you're gonna flip me oh
i'm slipping oh i'm doing a slip
jump beautiful
would you look at that what has happened
to my wife
what'd you look at what's up don't look
at that i'm from britain
how you feel about that cody god you're
so attractive
when you're inspired
[Laughter]
you ready one two three nope
oh [ __ ] oh just kills both of us okay
well whoa i know i want to be friends
with whatever it is
oh my god let's try
let's try it at the same time let's jump
from up here one
two three go we both
missed it
okay okay ready yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
one two three go
no i think it just kills you i don't
know if we could do anything
i like this i like this a lot so far
okay i thought you told me you didn't
point it
uh something oh i'm about to die
it's okay i'm about to die i'm about to
die
what is their objective oh that's right
get sucked off
by a vacuum voice it's time to hear from
our sponsor
raygon recon is disrupting the
electronics industry by designing
premium wireless audio for half the
price of other premium audio brands
with no compromises they sound great
with 6 hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and
a great noise isolating fit they're also
really comfortable honestly most of the
time i swear i can't even feel them in
my ears and in my opinion
they look great the wireless earbuds sit
in your ear really neatly with no ugly
dangly bits like wires or stems
and you can get them in a wide range of
fun colors and patterns for comfort
specifically you have a number of
different fit options
and even when i was wearing them while
going for a run they never fell out of
my ears i don't even think they moved
and i can't say that for any other audio
brand i use
it is wonderful so here's a shake test
for you see
but it's not just me you might know them
because the company was co-founded by
ray j and celebrities like snoop dogg
and mike tyson
are huge fans of them so if you're ready
to get yourself a pair click the link in
the description box or go to
buyrecon.com
alana to get 15 off your recon purchase
this is a boss fight whoa what what
dude i'm just trying to get my dick
sucked yeah
i'm just trying to [ __ ] a vacuum dude
what the hell
you aim it at the right answer up there
right in that mouth yeah
what does that mouth do you know we
would like to know
mechanics-wise actually pretty curious
for the gameplay
what that mouth does i would love if
somebody asked that
genuinely though genuinely um
what does that mouth do oh my god me to
do the bottom uh
okay i got to suck the boys up what i
can't like little what
like you gotta aim in his mouth oh
okay what is this [ __ ] attack warfare
that's a bit [ __ ] up oh
that's kind of cool though yeah he's
pretty you know
that's why we're dating that's why yeah
that's why i'm leaning on himself dude
i'm gonna be at bottom yeah that's what
i always suspected you know i'm glad
you're
out here openly admitting it it checks
out
dirt mixed with semen is a hell of a
concoction dude is he gonna throw crusty
socks at us
did i die i did did you die i did but i
brought myself back
it don't die there's one more
that's all i thought suck it sounded
like you said zuck
dark dude what are you up to you think
he's gonna host saturday night live next
that would be the [ __ ] weirdest thing
ever i would absolutely watch it though
oh my god that would be so awkward yeah
i have one where jeff bezos does it just
might [ __ ] around and see what happens
i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready
i'm giving you
give me a big meat get dunked on oh
yes you make him suck himself we
make him suck himself that's pretty
[ __ ] up
yeah suck your own eyes out dude
oh my god this is
is this is this pg
i've seen i'm a little uncomfortable i'm
a little i'm a little uncomfortable oh
my god
you made this man eat his own eyes just
now
that's nuts dude that's kind of [ __ ]
up who's this new friend
it's whatever it's gonna be a dildo it's
whatever she has sex with a hammer
oh interesting taste we have to find his
shaft
that's got to be quite heavy what are
you made of woman
she's wood whoa
dude gotta be careful about that i just
have this on my back
and a talking hammer now this is pod
racing oh
[Laughter]
can you do anything to me oh did it hit
you okay
it did a little bit yeah get rekt whoa
yeah
wonderful wonderful oh welcome to your
first
couples challenge our first couple's
challenge for one think about it
the size of the nails all right compared
to the side it's a small book
oh yeah it's a little handbook
i'm not entirely sure how this works but
i think maybe this like i do maybe this
got you got you
[ __ ] a jesus [ __ ]
oh no get out of here
what the [ __ ]
this is not at all fair i just keep
going to the last one that you went to
because you never doubled back on them
oh no
[ __ ] got him [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you doing
great now
what happened
yes all right so you use your little
nails
in an eye there you go go along here
and then i go we get dumped on
oh why would you do that mike i'm just
salty that you won you know
there's nothing like a couple's drop
from hill that would surely kill you you
know
we have fun why are you telling me not
to screw it up what
what do i oh i can move these platforms
okay i see
okay what's gonna be best for you here
though
so stop it there okay okay okay if we
do whip all right then
recall yes and you gotta jump up there
unless that's not right no you have to
jump to the other side i think
not up the top the top is on the other
way back okay [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm so sorry i'll show you away oh just
wait oh
my god
oh my i was like maybe i don't have to
dash
and like um
seems right i think and then we gotta
put the other one maybe like
sort of about here
nope you made it work all right
great oh did i do that too soon damn it
i died oh okay great it wasn't my fault
okay what the [ __ ] am i gonna do about
this
oh okay wait go
[Laughter]
okay and go
nope nope
okay like now yeah oh my god i almost
fell okay
another boss oh battle
think my bae oh
that grimy tuma did he just shoot out a
snail bomb
oh my god do you know how many people
die from those
no no you [ __ ] don't no you don't you
stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] dick [ __ ] dick
you can't do it i'll believe in you this
is stupid
very nice uh score [ __ ] off
okay well we're back to the start oh no
oh no oh my god
you got it okay okay [ __ ]
i keep not looking at the saw blades
this is the problem i'm having nope
you [ __ ] again alana amana
[Laughter]
ready okay okay yep i'm ready i'm ready
i'm ready [ __ ] you hold on
i died stupid wife
my stupid wife could just do anything
correct
this is not going ready for us yeah
okay i wanted to see where the nails
would fall go go go go go go go go go go
boom yes
yo what is he getting yo he's got a gun
this dude got a gun yeah this is his
voice
inside pretty [ __ ] up man oh look out
for the nails
uh okay why did it why does it have that
kind of functionality
built into it what is this machine oh my
god okay
okay he belongs to the loony bin don't
eat all right
there's something wrong with you i don't
have anyone ever told
[Music]
i feel like we just defeated a um serial
killer
yo i take back everything bad i haven't
said about her this shit's
[ __ ] dope what the [ __ ] that was
crazy yeah that was pretty sick
no don't go for me i'm the man
up with the patriarchy for once okay
up with the patriarchy nobody ever asks
how's the patriarchy you know
oh that's you put it on the thing are
you sure
i think that's a you situation oh
[Music]
what's wrong with his face that was rude
i'm sorry you have a beautiful place
let's go let's go
i see oh that's that's going to be a
good time
okay let's try this again because i have
to give myself hand jobs because you
won't touch me
[Laughter]
oh my god okay jesus
you just said so many words and meant
nothing with any of them jesus in it all
right
biscuits okay okay hold on i'll be back
yep okay i'm back oh my god he almost
got slapped again okay
he's done he's gonna do it he's gonna
die okay okay let's go get out let's go
let's go
yes just throw a little bit yes
oh look at that he loves it big daddy
toolbox
is the hammer dead i hope not we haven't
given him his shaft